Srinagar a ghost town troops on every
corner barricades everywhere in the
largest city in the indian-administered
Kashmir India's government says recent
troop reinforcements are to ensure
security and to maintain order as
Kashmiri see the effects of the
significant changes to their autonomy
and statehood they didn't tell us
anything and revoked article 370 all the
phone lines are down trains are not
working we haven't seen anything like
this in Kashmir in our lives migrant
workers who hope to find employment here
happen stranded for days internet is
down we can't access cash machines no
one is listening to apply no one cares
about us laborers in New Delhi this
prominent Kashmiri filmmaker is worried
about his elderly parents in Srinagar he
questions the timing of the government's
decision to revoke the state's autonomy
and divided into two federally
administered territories the one thing
about the timing of this decision is
that it seems awfully timed and so then
one is forced to wonder as to why this
would have happened and crudely yes the
Kashmir story has pushed the impending
economic crisis of the front pages for
this week and who knows you know until
the next round of elections legal
challenges are already being planned the
first public interest litigation against
the government's decision has been filed
and they are more expected some
constitutional experts say that there
are some legal loopholes that the judges
may conceal
the process had a is a certain amount of
scut constitutional skullduggery which I
expect the Supreme Court or any other
Constitutional Court to look at very
closely constitutions do not work on the
whim of a few people alone no matter how
high they are in the constitutional
structure India's government led by the
party turned the party of hid the
Nationals sake wish me special status
was discriminatory and with a change of
status it will be open to investment and
more jobs for now these shops in
Srinagar are closed and no one knows for
how long
priyanka Gupta al Jazeera New Delhi